hi there today we'll look at deep
ensembles a lost landscape perspective
by stanislav fort
hui and balaji lakshmi narayanan
this paper on a high level explains the
lost landscape of
deep ensemble models so ensembles of
deep neural network
and it hypothesizes and it shows through
experiments
that each member of the ensemble by
means of being
initialized at a random point will go
and through optimization
go and end up at a different place in
weight space
and therefore the deep ensemble is able
to capture different modes of the
functional space
of these space of solutions they compare
these two bayesian networks which are
sort of promised to do the same thing
but they often only characterize a
single mode and therefore they don't
generalize as well
so join me exploring this paper i think
it's pretty cool paper
uh the experiments are cleverly designed
to show
what they're supposed to show and i
generally enjoy this type of research
because
it's kind of an explanatory research
that shows you what's going on
inside of these networks rather than you
know chasing the next
state-of-the-art number it's also an
example of research that you can
still do uh while you're you don't have
you know giant resources of compute even
though this
is by deep mind uh but i do believe that
this kind of research is still
you know wide open and available to
academia
and whereas the other kind the
state-of-the-art kind
slowly goes into more and more of the
money game
all right in any case uh join me in
reading this paper if you like it
share it out leave a comment to think uh
to
tell me what you think and leave a like
if you enjoyed it all right
so we'll start off the abstract says
deep ensembles
have been empirically shown to be a
promising approach for improving
accuracy
uncertainty and out-of-distribution
robustness of deep learning
models so what are deep ensembles really
quick
and an ensemble model and we're in the
classification setting so in the
classification setting
we have data points and each data point
has features
so which are the x x is some kind of d
dimensional feature and then you have y
which
is the label so that's
in some let's say that's some natural
number
or something like this or is element of
a class
set ah that's the complex numbers
it's it's element of some um some some
bounded set of class labels so it's
either a cat or a dog or
you know what what whatever you want
so you have a data set of these things
and your plan is to
use x to predict why if you build an
ons if you build a model a deep null
network for example for this task you
would simply characterize this function
here you would parameterize it
as a deep neural networks of many many
layers
if you build an ensemble now what you
would do is you would take the data set
and simply train multiple different ones
of these deep neural networks
so you'll train multiple different ones
and if you now want to classify data
point
you'll input that data point into all of
these three
and at the end you would somehow
aggregate and there are different
methods of doing this but the
most obvious one is simply either to
aggregate by
the mean or the mode
median whatever you want you can also
kind of also learn something here
but you can just average the predictions
and that will
usually give you a better prediction
than if you only have one model
so this is called an ensemble model and
if the ensemble members
these things here are neural networks or
deep networks this is called a deep
ensemble so why
do we hope to become better that's the
the point of this paper is to show what
happens in the lost landscape of these
deep neural networks
and why do they perform better than
um other methods that are supposed to
achieve the same thing
so usually when you build an ensemble
model
what are you hoping for you're hoping to
sort of
learn a generalizable function
and they have this drawing right here um
where it's a bit of a you have to sort
of think differently than you usually do
so
on the x-axis you have the space of
solutions
so imagine that your uh your neural
network only has a single
weight so that this axis here is that
single weight
or you can projector or whatnot this is
the space of
different solutions so after you
optimize
you land somewhere on this axis and you
can see
that there is a solid line which
represents the accuracy on the training
set
and then there is a dashed line which
represents the accuracy of the
validation set
for a given parameter so what you
usually do is
you optimize one neural network to
its very best training accuracy so let's
say you start off
here what you would do is you would see
my training accuracy is
this high i need a different color right
here is this high
and you calculate the gradient and you
could do a gradient descent
and that means you go down the loss up
the accuracy so you go
over and over and over until you reach
this point right here
where you have maximum training accuracy
and then you'll suffer some
generalization loss like you know so
right here
it suffers some generalization loss
because the validation accuracy at that
point
isn't as high but generally it's
correlated as you can see
uh by the general overlap of these two
lines of these two shapes right here
okay so this is called a maximum a
posteriori
estimate you simply optimize one neural
network
until the best training error
there are different approaches right
here there are approaches that say
okay we can do we could do better so
first of all what you see right here is
rather peculiar and you might not be
used to this that there are different
peaks right here there are different
peaks
as you can see in the training and the
validation error so they're correlated
and the idea is that neural networks
are very non-linear and we've known from
other papers that
they have many many local minima and
in fact so this is one of the astounding
things about neural network
most of these minima are performing
equally well so even though the neural
network has
different local minima they all perform
about equally well and other papers even
say they're all sort of connected on a
low
loss landscape so there are many many
things
that are still mysterious about neural
network
but we know that there are multiple
minima and we know
that we basically need to find one of
them and
it doesn't really matter which one it
they all perform
sort of equally well
now as you can as you might imagine
there are people who
aren't really satisfied with this and
their approach is to say why don't we
just capture
this entire curve right here so if we
could build a model that could not only
you know not only tell us at this point
right here you're this good
but could tell us that at any point
right
how good we are capture the entire
distribution of solutions and these are
usually
um in the category of the bayesian
neural
networks they try to capture the entire
distribution
of course that's not really feasible
because you know you always have to
calculate that posterior
and so what they end up doing is they do
some
approximation and usually they do some
sort of a
multivariate gaussian approximation
because you can calculate posteriors in
closed form and so on
and this paper this paper's hypothesis
is that these
can only usually capture one of these
peaks so they
are very able to capture the
surrounding right here they can capture
very accurately
what happens around this particular peak
they are very aware of the shape of the
curvature here
and can tell you a lot of things about
it so they can tell you for example
that the validation so that you
might want to be a bit over here rather
than over here
but they cannot they don't generally
know about these other
modes because they are only
approximations
they generally don't produce multi-modal
solutions
another approach is a deep ensemble
now this paper shows that in general
if you train a deep ensemble what will
happen is because you
randomly initialize the deep ensemble at
some points
it will happen that if you do gradient
descent on all of them they will
end up sort of covering all these
different modes
they still they don't have an idea of
you know the curvature oh sorry this one
shouldn't go here this one should go
here the curve they don't really
know about the curvature but they will
give you these different
minima right here and therefore they can
capture
the landscape much much more easily if
you know that these
three are minima you sort of
it might look something like this and
that's a hell of a lot better
than simply the bayesian approximation
that only is able to capture one of the
peaks but really accurately
so their hypothesis here is that deep
ensembles
do this job of capturing the different
modes of the functional space much
better
than the bayesian methods
and it is why the deep methods sorry why
the deep ensembles work
so well because they end up in different
minima
and that is it's a really interesting
proposition
and what i find really interesting as
well are the experiments
that they do to show this so they have a
lot of these experiments right here
uh first of all to the setup they use
c410
c4 100 and so on and on c410
you can see right here they use a small
cnn medium cnn
and a resnet now the small and medium
cnns their accuracy is really really
subpar
so um take the results here with some
grain of salt because there are effects
in this neural network that are really
qualitatively different
if you are seriously underperforming um
like this one like if you have a
seriously too small network
rather than a large network now they do
verify all of their things also with
this large network and ninety percent
accuracy
um is is acceptable for c410
i don't think there's the big
qualitative difference between 90 and 95
and so on but
the 64 if it were only this
i would be rather critical of this work
but it's fine to
if you if you see the effect at 64
and then some of the effects you check
to carry over to the 90
one i'm going to generally believe you
okay so first of all
what they do here is they look at a
training trajectory of just a single
uh run so this paper is
half about ensembles but also half
generally about
what what does training of neural
networks do and they reach some very
very cool conclusions that even are
independent
of deep ensembles so here the first
thing we do is
we have some initial random
initialization in weight space of your
weight
and then you do gradient descent and you
run and you run
right and you get to some minima right
here some minimum
right here and then you do a second
one so you initialize
somewhere else and because you
initialize somewhere else you run you
run your run
you end up at a different minimum okay
this is a
property so these are not convex
functions right we know about neural
networks you'll end up at different
minima
but the minima they will they will
perform
about equally well so the question is
do those different minima that perform
equally well
describe the same function or are they
fundamentally different functions
that just happen to reach the same
accuracy
and the the question is
very interesting and this paper
attempts to answer that so here you can
see in the description
on the left cosine similarity between
checkpoints to measure
weight space alignment along
optimization
trajectory so we only consider
one of these runs only consider the left
one for example
and you plot it here and here
this later one comes later sorry so you
plot the left
only a single run and you ask yourself
the checkpoint
that i have after epoch 20. how similar
is it to the checkpoint that i have
after
epoch 5 that would be right here
now we have to read up how they compare
the checkpoints
and this is weight space alignment okay
so weight space alignment it basically
means how much do the
weights align in the cosine fashion as
you can see right here
this is simply the cosine between the
weights this is one way of comparing two
functions if two functions align in
weight space
there's a decent chance that they
describe the same thing
so as you can see here we go
as we go down the optimization
trajectory of course
each one is similar to themselves but
you can see that there is kind of a
shift right here so
at the beginning the zeroth checkpoint
is very dissimilar to the checkpoint at
the end
but after very short while you kind of
cross over
and then all these checkpoints right
here are
sort of similar so the
you if you just look at two rows you
look at the bottom row
and you look at the top row the bottom
row tells you
how similar are the checkpoints during
training to the initial checkpoint
and you can see pretty quickly they are
very dissimilar
so at this point right here there is
kind of a
dissimilarity happening where the
checkpoint goes away from its
initialization
to something else and the top row tells
you how similar are they to
where the network ends up and
you can see that there appears to be a
period
in let's say here where this shift away
starts
up until here where it's kind of
not similar to anything but then after
that
after here everything is similar to the
final checkpoint
okay so this is sort of tells us
a hypothesis is that you initialize
randomly
somewhere you have this lost landscape
right you initialize randomly
somewhere here and then you go go go and
at some point you fall into one of one
of those valleys and then you simply go
to that
um to that valley if you initialize
somewhere differently you can see that
at the beginning you might be
here somewhere and then you fall into
that valley over here
and after that you're pretty much set
so this is going to be our hypothesis
from now on that
in these neural networks you the
initialization
is basically you you are somewhere and
you kind of
meander around a bit until you happen to
go into one of these directions
which happens pretty quickly and then
you fall into
a hole basically and that's that's
rather
convex setting in that thing
okay a really interesting thing that
they do
is um a really interesting thing is that
they check the disagreement of
predictions
so you might think that if a
neural network achieves 65 or 90 let's
call it 90
accuracy on c410 right that there are
just you know there there this
data set that's a hundred percent and
they're just these
ten percent over here that are just the
hardest right
and the more you train the more are you
you're able to push this boundary
to the right so if you train more if you
have a better network
you're just able to explain more and
more of the samples
however um this pa this experiment here
is going to show that this is not the
case
what they measure is the disagreement in
predictions which basically means that
if i there is this data set the
validation data set
and if i have one random initialization
and i train it to 90
accuracy it will have it will
say these it will not be able to
classify
these here but if i have the same
network but a different initialization
it might not be able to classify these
over here but we'll
be perfectly able to classify these over
here right
this is a very also very interesting
property
and you can see right here the
disagreement
of predictions as you go through the
training
so again we're going to look at the
bottom and the top row
so the bottom row and the top row red
is very disagreeing blue is very
agreeing
you can see again that um
oh i introduced again i introduced the
different runs i'm already taking this
away from later
we are just looking at one single run
for now
this this is a result that's going to
come up later when we look at two
different runs of the same neural
network and that's the astounding part
okay here
we're just going to look at one run
again during training
so we can see right here at the
beginning of course every checkpoint
agrees with itself
on the predictions however
you can see that pretty quickly the
checkpoints start disagreeing
very quickly everything is read right
here
however on the top you can see how much
how much do these checkpoints agree with
the
end with the 30th epoch checkpoint
and see that there is a period that is
red right from here
to let's say here and then after that
they all start agreeing so from here on
out
it's all pretty blue which basically
means that
[Music]
that they agree with the last
checkpoint so with the
that all of these agree with the
end of the training again this is our
hypothesis here that once you're in this
valley that the function kind of stays
the same and you only sort of micro
optimize the function however at the
beginning you decide into
which of those valleys you want to go
and these
different initializations will lead you
to different valleys and that's what
they
show right here so they do a t-sne plot
of predictions t-sne is a method to
project to down-project
high-dimensional vectors and this is the
weight space projected to two dimensions
so t-snex is one
and two these are rather arbitrary um
it's just the
if you think of a pca it's the
directions of maximum variance and you
can see
the three different runs they
immediately
at the beginning right here they
immediately go you can see they have
they do
large distances at the beginning between
the steps of optimization
and they do in very different directions
just by means of being initialized at
different points and
having maybe a bit of noise in the
training process
but once they are at the particular
location they sort of just
kind of bounce around right here and try
to find
the best minima in that region
so this is our first indication
that the if we train the same network
multiple times with random
initializations
it's going to end up at mult at
different places
and what we're wondering is we already
know
that a single network is very different
at the end than at the beginning of
training
what we want to know is our two networks
also very different even though they're
trained on the same objective
just because they are at different
places in the weight space doesn't mean
they are functionally that different
there are symmetries
and it's going to turn out yes they
actually are very very different
so this is right here here you can see
two different things and we're going to
read the
plot along with it just so i remember
what i'm seeing here so using two
different architectures okay
for each of these architectures the left
subplot shows the cosine similarity
between the different solution weight
space
and the right subplot shows the fraction
of labels on which the predictions from
different solutions disagree
okay so it's the same as before the left
is the alignment and now it's not during
training
now we restart independently we train
the same network 10 different times and
after that we're going to compare the 10
different solutions
remember these all achieve roughly the
same accuracy
on the data sets and this is the same
whether you go to a
big architecture like this resnet 20 or
to a
small architecture like this small cnn
right here
you can see that every single solution
of
course agrees a lot with itself that's
the diagonal right here
but it's completely it's not a line it's
completely orthogonal
to all the other solutions so all the
solutions in weight space
are orthogonal now there's still the
chance that there's you know some
symmetry and weight space
uh because you know if i if i have a
neural network i can just
exchange the exchange the connections
and
if i also exchange the neurons then it
will be the same function
however you can see right here that they
completely disagree
so this small cnn remember it had like a
a 65
accuracy the solutions the red here they
disagree on 25
of the labels so that this is exactly
this effect
we saw before we train one solution and
it will not be able to classify
these parts of the validation data set
and we we train the same network
with the same data set with the same
loss with everything the same
again just from a random initialization
that's different
it will end up equally performing
equally well but it will make the
mistakes on an entirely different
set of the validation data points like
this is rather
astounding i feel because i think most
people are of the
of the idea that uh the kind of
data points have an intrinsic hardness
and
if if we get to 70 accuracy
it will always be the same 70 of data
points that we misclassify or sorry
that we correctly classify this is not
the case
and this is one thing i think this paper
and this line of research does pretty
cool is to look at these
networks in terms of their prediction
agreement so they go further and they
compare this to four different methods
so they say
okay ensembles um ensembles are one
method
of kind of doing these getting different
solutions
which means we start from random
initializations but there are other ones
so for example there is just place this
correctly here
random subspace sampling so what does it
mean let's see we start at an
optimized solution so you train a
network one single network
and then we choose a random direction at
v
in weight space we step in that
direction by choosing different values
of t
looking at the predictions at
configurations theta zero
plus t v we repeat this from many
different v
but always the same theta zero so in our
original
kind of drawing of this thing we
optimize
one single network let's say that's here
and then we sort of wiggle around in
here
into different random directions now of
course there's only one random direction
right here
if maybe we can look at this at at the
so if
here we have the lost landscape and
maybe over
here there is a bit of a of a thing and
over here there is a
bit of a you you thought i was gonna
draw
um okay so we we start
here and maybe that converges to
somewhere here
so what we're going to do is we're going
to select random directions in that
space
and we're just going to go a few steps
into this direction and compare
the weights now here you can already see
by the way i'm drawing it
that this will probably make you stay in
the same
region and uh our hope with ensembles is
of course is that they are able to
capture
all of the three different uh modes
right here
but it is a way to obtain different
solutions that all also perform
quite well if you only perturb your
solution by a little bit
it also works quite well and you can
build
an ensemble out of these methods right
here you can build an ensemble out of
these
in fact these bayesian methods if
you do these approximations with
gaussians that's pretty much what they
will end up doing is they will end up
characterizing the local
the local landscape around one of these
minimum
but here we simply do it by randomly
stepping into a direction
that's the first method that we're going
to investigate to obtain
an ensemble of different solutions so
deep ensembles means we initially random
we
randomly initialize many times and then
train
from scratch each member this method
here
means we start from an or from a
solution and we simply perturb it into
random directions
the next thing we can do is we can do
dropout
subspace dropout we again start at an
optimized solution
apply dropout with randomly chosen
probability
again our hypothesis is going to be that
this is going to keep the network rather
in
the sort of same kind of functional mode
and
not switch over diagonal gaussian
subspace
again we start from an optimized
solution you can see the pattern
and here we actually do some sort of a
gaussian approximation
to the functional space we calculate a
mean
and a standard deviation and we
draw samples of the parameters from that
distribution
and then the same in a low rank regime
and here you see what happens so here is
these things for example the random
subspaces
here is this overlapped with the plot we
saw before
so here we have three different
trajectories
of runs and then at the end of each
trajectory we take the best solution
and we do this random exploration around
it
and this here is the t-sne the t-snip
projection
now this isn't i have to say this isn't
the projection of the weights itself
um sorry i did not say that before this
is a projection
of the predictions i believe of a subset
of data points
so this is the this is the prediction
projection
of that and you can see that if we
perturb the solutions like this
all of these solutions all of these
ensembles they rather they stay in their
in their basin of attraction as you can
see right here
so with a deep ensemble we would build
an ensemble
that um sorry sorry sorry
we would build an ensemble that combines
this point
and this point and this point whereas
here
we will simply either build an ensemble
that
that combines points in here or will
build an ensemble that combines points
in here
and so on and you'll see this for all
the different methods that we consider
here especially
the gaussian methods and that's a hint
to
why even though bayesian networks
explicitly try to capture the entire
distribution right here what they'll end
up doing is they'll
simply end up capturing a single mode
and not and that's important because the
single mode
is always functionally sort of equal we
saw that
this is a train training the trajectory
and
at the end of training after like this
step right here
all the functions are pretty much the
same right they pretty much agree
with the end optimum whereas
between the runs they these functions
completely disagree
with each other so it is important if we
want to build an ensemble to capture as
many of these modes as possible
and only the ensemble the deep ensembles
can do that so far so this is another
experiment
where they show uh this lost landscape
and i
i really like these uh kind of plots so
what you see here is a plane it's a 2d
plane
and the 2d plane is described by three
points
so one point is the origin you see right
here the origin
that's the origin of that's the zero in
weight space
okay then what you have are the two
optima so you'd
run an optimization two different times
once it's initialized here and it runs
to here
and once it's initialized here and it
runs to
here okay so that defines the plane that
we're going to look at
now they for each single pixel in this
plane or actually for each single pixel
in this
half circle right here they evaluated
the networks
um so well what you'll do is simply you
do linear combination
of these weight of the weight vector
here at this optimum the weight vector
here at this optimum
and you can for each point here defines
a neural network with those weights
right and you can evaluate it
and that's what you get this is the
accuracy of the neural network at that
point
so here you can see very very clearly
that um there are these two
different modes right here so each
even though they're initialized super
close to each other right
you can see this right here they're
initialized super close to each other
because they are this is the flat area
right here that we saw before because
they are
in the flat area um
[Music]
they're even though they're initialized
pretty close the red one
is a little bit more to this basin of
attraction the blue one is a little bit
more to this base of attraction so they
move over and as soon as they're in it's
like
boom they go to the minimum of that
basin and this area is rather convex
and this area is rather convex and in
the middle you can see
is a less is more loss
so no solution will go there that's how
you get these different
minima that's how you get these
different modes and you can see the
accuracy or from the color is going to
be the same
in each of the in each of the
valleys consistent with our what we know
so far
now here the pink stripe is a
gaussian exploration so if you now
do a gaussian perturbation gaussian
exploration around this minimum
you basically you can see again you
don't get out of this valley you don't
you're not going to go
two different modes the weight space is
just too large
and you're going to simply be stuck
in there so the only chance almost you
have is to initialize again
and hope that you end up in a different
place and i guess my hypothesis is that
there are
many many more of these um valleys of
these
basins than there you can you could ever
capture so basically every single
initialization
that is different will lead you to a
different uh one of these basins
i guess it's only a matter of this size
so here again they do a function
similarity
so in this case it's the function
similarity to optimum one
and this is again how many of the labels
agree with the optimum right
here and you can see that within this
basin of attraction
you have fairly high overlap of the
functional similarity
but here none right so
15 or so it's not going to be zero
because they're going to agree on
like some of the examples i guess
there's still something like intrinsic
hardness but um they they agree on
almost none of the labels at least i
guess if you normalize by
their base accuracy so even though
optimum 2 is performing
as well it is functionally extremely
dissimilar to optimum 1. so these
describe
really different functions and i really
don't know
what to make of this other than you know
this each one of these is maybe sort of
deciding to
look at different features in the in the
data set
right to or to maybe build different
high level features from the same low
level features
and maybe we're still under
parameterizing these models
uh because not a single model can sort
of look at both
features at the same time as evidenced
by the fact that
each of these is always going to one of
these things
or it could be that in fact the task
is way too simple and it's it it can be
solved in like
uh 500 different ways and
each of these optima is simply one way
of solving the task one way of combining
feature
and it's actually completely an
overspecified problem that's another
hypothesis it would be i guess
interesting to look at these things and
i'm sure there's work on this
so you can see the same thing for
optimum two right here
where okay go away
where you can see that optimum one
it agrees uh almost nothing with
optimum two right it doesn't it doesn't
agree there's not even a
hint of a valley right here in the terms
of functional similarity
that is very very interesting so
it really means that these two things
describe two different functions
they do these other plots right here
that they call diversity
versus accuracy plots so
what they'll do is they are going
to have different models and they're
going to look at them
in terms of their diversity and their
accuracy so here the y-axis is going to
be
how different are these
functions and that's going to be again
in fraction of labels changed normalized
by the
base accuracy so here you can see
we always start from this baseline
optimum this baseline optimum has
zero diversity zero because
it agrees with itself on all the
on all the different labels of course
and then we're going to
disturb that using our four methods that
we
defined before so we're going to
randomly subspace we're going to drop
out we're going to
gaussian perturbed and so on and the
more we perturb it
the more diverse our function is going
to be naturally right because we perturb
the function
it starts disagreeing more and more and
more with our original
optimum however what we also expect is
if you know if we are in the local
optimum
and maybe here and you know maybe the
validation accuracy
is sort of beside it or a little bit
larger and so on so if we perturb it a
little bit
you know that might not make too much to
our accuracy but if we perturb it a lot
you know we go actually up the lost
landscape and then we get less accuracy
also on the validation set so that's
what you see
right here in these um in this this
curve
right here as you make the function
more diverse so you perturb it a little
bit you see that your accuracy doesn't
suffer too much you kind of stay at the
same accuracy
but as if you make it more and more and
more diverse you can see that the
accuracy suffers
until the diversity of one basically
means that you disagree on the maximum
amount of labels that you can and so
you're sort of sort of out of this
valley right here
and also you can see that your accuracy
goes to zero so the more
these functions disagree the less their
accuracy is
that seems natural however you can see
that
these red stars right here they seem to
be
also very different they seem to not
agree with the
original baseline optimum but they seem
to be doing perfectly fine in terms of
accuracy
be at the same accuracy and those are
the
independent optima those are the optima
from runs where we initialized at a
different point and then also
trained and that again is evidence for
the fact
that there are probably other optima far
away
uh where these different initializations
find this here so they are very
different in terms of functional space
they're quite far apart
they predict different things however in
terms of
loss they're almost the same or actually
the same
so this is very very cool experiments
right here and they do this for the
different um
for different architectures and you can
see that
especially the larger architectures this
actually happens more pronounced
and they also make the point of saying
if you go to harder problems like a c4
100 or an image net
this this effect is more pronounced that
you can see these here are closer
together as a curve
and these these are the the
independent optima so i hope
you're all you're already on board um
and still know why we're doing these
things we're doing these things
because we want to build some sort of
ensemble
that captures the distribution of
solutions
in order to generalize better now we
have two
options either we start kind of
from a an optimum and
characterize the space around that
optimum which is what these methods do
right here
and what also the bayesian methods do
this even though they don't want to
because they do these approximations
because they're intractable
they're going to end up doing this
or our other our other
option is to restart training a bunch of
times
and then we end up at different optima
and the
point of the paper is it's better to do
that um than to build the ensemble out
of
the of these gaussian methods or of
these perturbation methods
and the paper i guess the main claim of
the paper is why that happens and it
happens because the ensemble members
obtain
different minima that are functionally
different
okay so
um exactly that's what they do here so
they now build ensembles out of these
different things
and you can see
that here on the x axis you have the
ensemble size so how many
ensemble members do you have and the
dashed lines here are the baseline
accuracies if you just have a single
model and the
um the test accuracy
is plotted on the y-axis now i actually
was
i was not that's not correct you always
built the ensemble
out of random initializations but on top
of that you do these things
so what you can see right here is
if i have this classifier which is my
original classifier
and i add on top of that this pca
gaussian you know perturbation
stuff i increase in accuracy
okay however if i build an
ensemble i increase in accuracy if i
build an ensemble
out of 10 members i increase in accuracy
this much okay and then if
because i can do both things so if i
increase
if i do an ensemble and then on top of
that to the bc i guess i gain
another this much right here so
that's sort of evidence for the fact
that you'd rather build an ensemble
than do this um these other methods of
of approximating the bayesian posterior
of weights
so yes i'm i'm i'm sort of convinced
i hope you are too and they do
a lot of they do us some more
experiments right here where you can see
that the difference
between so this is single mo sorry
this is um i guess
here accuracy oh yeah if you
this is the out of distribution test so
you can take a data set
and you can corrupt it corruption so
there are
predefined data sets but you can also do
it yourself you crop it you can
do luminancy whatever you can
destroy parts of the image you can see
that having more ensemble members so
this is your
original models here is how they sync
with increasing
corruption it almost doesn't matter
which ones of these methods you do you
see the bottom one is the original model
and you gain a little bit by doing these
things
but not nearly as much by building an
ensemble
and going here or actually an ensemble
of two members or of five members
in which case you jump this much in
accuracy
so these ensembles from different
initializations are also
very very um are also very
good at countering corruption which you
see
also here
yeah so this is the js divergence okay
i've
read that but let's not go here video is
already too long
and this is the last thing is on
imagenet test set and the imagenet
corrupted set where they pretty much
show the same thing
it's not as pronounced here but you can
see pretty much
how the different
if you go from single model to ensemble
with two members to ensemble four
members
there is a general upwards trend and the
general upwards trend is much
less pronounced within each ensemble so
if you go
just go from method to method then it is
between
the different groups of ensembles
meaning that the
ensemble is a much more pronounced
effect than these other effects
so i hope i have convinced you a little
bit
of how these subspaces look like how the
lost landscape of neural networks look
like
especially the fact that there are these
different
minima and the random initializations
will almost always hit
these different minima and the
interesting part is that even though
these different minima perform equally
well
they are functionally very different and
an
ensemble of differently initialized and
independently optimized models can
actually
capture these different modes of the
functional space and therefore if you
build an ensemble out of that
it will generalize better because it
kind of can draw information from all of
those different modes
rather than if you do some sort of
bayesian network which will
because you have to approximate usually
with gaussians will end up
only covering one of these modes
that was that is sort of a a good
summary
of what this paper says i again i enjoy
research like this because it's easy and
it gives
it kind of makes you thinks right so
i'll i'll be
thinking about these things for a while
now and thinking of new kind of
experiments that walk could do and yeah
as i said this research is still wide
open we don't know so many things about
neural network
and you know tell me tell me what you
think is going on actually that would be
very
interesting and yeah i'll see you next
time bye